we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i received a
voicemail about another element of the
weird signing ceremonies that Donald
Trump is doing take a listen to this hi
David I just watched your video on the
Trump signing with Justin Trudeau and I
just wanted to comment on how I loved
how Justin Trudeau keep looking up at
the camera like geez him from the office
that just absolutely entertained me to
no end and I also wanted to comment and
ask you about Trump's custom Sharpie pin
it looked like when he pulled out his
pin he had to like struggle to remove
the cap a little bit and it looked like
he was signing that document with a
really big permanent marker where
everyone else had a ten yeah so thank
you very much yeah this has been brought
up a few times so number one people have
been saying that that signing video of
Trump signing this new trade document
with the French I'm sorry with the
Canadian Prime Minister and the Mexican
president that either the intro theme
from the office or the intro theme from
Curb Your Enthusiasm should have been
playing to really give us the full scope
of what it was that was going on there
which I completely agree with I have
noticed that Trump uses not a
normal-sized Sharpie but it seems to be
the big boy we actually have a couple of
those in our studio and I use them for
like addressing extremely large packages
that I need to send out I don't know why
Trump insists Pat on using those
gigantic sharpies I I haven't heard any
comment from the company that makes
sharpies I don't know if it's called
Sharpie or if it has some other name but
why can't he just use a normal pen I
don't understand wasn't there some
contention about him signing in the
wrong place I guess if he has such a
large sharpie he could just be signing
everywhere on that documented on that
document in the right place in the wrong
place just about everywhere yeah it's
very weird I don't I don't know why he
has to do that and I don't know how he
got the idea of doing it maybe it's
something from his old corporate days
but it's once again like many things
Trump does maybe it is
representative of Trump trying to foment
his masculinity maybe he's lacking in
other areas where he thinks that having
a big marker will sort of make up for I
don't really know but it is weird and I
don't understand why he's doing it we
have a great bonus show today we will
talk about Luxembourg becoming the first
country to make public transportation
free completely free they can afford it
trust me folks we will also talk about
Baltimore drivers wanting Baltimore to
cut down on what are called squeegee
kids and I have a few stories related to
that and lastly California is now the
first state to require require solar
panels on all new homes all of those
stories and more on the bonus show get
access support the show become a member
at WWJ pakman.com I'll speak to you then